hello everybody my name is markiplier
and once again it is very dark in my
room which means that it's time for the
joy of creation reborn now this is an
updated version of the game shout out to
Nixon on Twitter who is the developer
this game who helped get me this early
version of the new update which includes
both Bonnie right there and foxy right
there so this is gonna be an interesting
exercise because now there are game
modes with which I can explore so I'm
gonna start with Freddy I'm gonna see
what the new game mode is for Freddy and
then I'm gonna move on to Bonnie and if
there's enough time I'm gonna move on to
foxy but we shall see very soon so let's
get into it
first floor ignited Freddy's at the name
of it that's a sweet name ignited Freddy
ignited by the flames of hell out his
butthole alright oh my god Freddy boo
let's see collect five objects within
one minute generic objects that can be
dildos are into the timer's counting
down right now holy [ __ ] you didn't tell
me that there was gonna be stuff I don't
know what object alright oh god I'm dead
already
I didn't know that I was gonna be
bothered oh that didn't sound good I
love the flailing wildly of my arms it
kind of mimics the panic that I'm
experiencing in this moment that's an
object oh god I'm dead hi
are you doing well that went off to a
poor start
what the hell happened I don't know
oh come on give me a goddamn break here
I need to adjust my microphone I'm just
gonna die that's all that's gonna happen
to me I'm gonna die a horrible death of
death poisoning ah god damn it we're in
the flashlight mmm oh that doesn't sound
good
holy [ __ ] oh I ain't gonna go good let
me just whip my arms back and forth with
my arms back and forth
where's these goddamn objects there's
one a baseball cap oh that's margarine
terrifying stop getting caught on
doorways you dickbag that another object
you Oh God
two objects remaining I don't know what
or where they are oh boy I think I lost
them nope definitely not nope didn't
losing been losing been losing almost
that time probably gonna die oh [ __ ] was
that an object to my left
Oh objective failed alright maybe I
didn't want to my dad or something
that's where the slow sweet embrace of
death is gonna encroach upon me oh that
was an object a mug okay then
Oh No
change your mind I understand he
hesitated a little bit he didn't know if
you wanted to hug me or murder me that
is goddamn terrifying just hearing him
thumping behind me I'm gonna crank it up
even louder okay so this time I'm not
gonna stick around this is an object
right here isn't it yes it is
well that's not too all right right away
right away right away holy [ __ ] oh oh by
the way ready for Freddy well I don't
know there's a Freddy poster right here
oh wait a minute oh oh no oh no oh no
he's looking at the wall why are you
waiting
ready
so I'm just having fun damn it
ah damn one thing again
nope can't find it I'm [ __ ]
just like goddamn poster why is it so
hard to find we want you to do it the
collection mechanic is random even if
they're inconsistent places but there's
some slight randomness to it so
obviously they're distributed a little
differently than they would be but there
is still some randomness to it so it's
kind of just a little douchey it's a
small element of douche oh [ __ ] I need
that I believe the coming [ __ ]
oh that's bad that's bad that's bad of
course top I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm not okay
apparently I'm not I just I missed out
on a door that there was probably an
item though because like I had to run
away from him I couldn't have gone in
the dead-end room if that would have
been the death of me yeah that there
here aha hey I win I'm a winner
cuz I eventually learned whether oh gosh
okay well I got that that's good and now
I'm gonna move on to bond bond because
bond bond apparently is different than
Freddie I don't know if that's in a good
way but we're gonna find out what way
that is so bear with me
nice eyeballs let's hide give me a big
hug there buddy boo all right we're
gonna go and see what Bonnie's all that
basement ignited Bonnie ooh
different area I wonder why they're
calling nighted I have a feeling it's
gonna be the same collection mechanic
but the only problem I have with the
collection mechanic is that it's random
and I have to learn yes II collect items
well sorry Zack yeah my goddamn mouse
what well here we go
okay got it don't worry it's fine
everything's fine Oh everything's
probably not fine hey should I be
worried I think I am worried all right a
minutes not a lot of time make it like
two minutes maybe I don't even see a
single item here I'm just trying to go
through a little calmly to get my
bearings but though there's one same
thing
telephone great for phone guy to call me
in the deepest darkest nights then bug
me yeah all right I'm gonna let the time
run out on this one because I don't
think I'm gonna be able to get through
hey bonbon oh it's my old friend bonbon
why does a security camera down here is
this like I'm supposed to be something
with a five nights at freddys Oh God
why the back of my head got is floated
up against the wall you got a problem
mate you wanna fight Oh God
well that's moderately terrifying all
righty then oh wow why he didn't see me
he couldn't have seen me now see I was
just a problem with this okay there's an
object it's the phone again oh god damn
it
hi Barney are you doing how the the
thunking I can only assume that the
chomping isn't biting on my frontal lobe
I'm gonna give it one more try actually
I just wanted to see what would happen
if that happened I mean I don't know why
I expected anything different than
sudden and instantaneous death that's
the phone isn't it oh hey found some
it's good to have something haven't been
able to found nothing fan something good
okay and then the phone's gonna be right
over here then okay I guess I could take
this as a training day and I'm assuming
that Bonnie is probably guarding all the
good stuff over in his area Oh another
phone yeah two phones
oh it doesn't sound good I can't rightly
tell which way is coming down I don't
like this
oh you have gone this way have
moderately terrifying is it coming this
way
why is it coming this way hey buddy are
you down there I can't tell is he on top
of me oh where is he where is he I can't
see anything I don't want to turn on my
light oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
we gotta go turn up I don't know where I
am
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] me okay all right I think that's
enough for now
I want to end that there no i'ma try
foxy in another episode because this is
gonna take a while to get good and I'm
not good but I'm gonna get good so thank
you everybody so much for watching I'll
get to foxy soon enough and thank you
Nixon for giving me an early build and
thanks for working so hard this is
really cool the only thing I'd say is
that the collection mechanic I it hasn't
been tried to in Slenderman and then it
was try it out because it adds just a
level of randomness that isn't entirely
fun because it doesn't seem like you're
accomplishing something and that's the
only criticism I'd say there's a very
unique thing and I like it a lot I like
it a lot and there's a lot of potential
there and I imagine this is not final
so take everything I say with a grain of
salt this is really cool and very scary
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see